今日はスピーカー付です
今日は極端な言語学習その2です
まあいえば極端私は極端な言語が九州です
photo パフィンの勉強が大好きなんですよ今書く
先週言うだけ言った通り3つの言葉
ページ者と荒北登録を勉強してます
幕2頭はそんな3つの全然違った言葉を同時に勉強しないんですけどね
認めます話題がちょっと極端です普通の
まあ言葉を勉強樹脂ている人たちですね外国語を勉強している
皆さんは一つの言葉しか勉強してないんですよね
だけども勉強するぞのカテリーナ名君書士が一緒なんですよ
一緒なんですよまず第一
基板のもう問題はなぜこの言葉を勉強するかと
日本にその何ですか
1億に3000万の人間が住んでますかなぁ
その日本のその島国で
えべつにいい案は英語で
英語で話す一応はないから何のために
英語メインあれが中国語スペイン語を勉強しないといけないのか
それは当然な質問だと思います
まあそれはもうジョンソンのその通り区
ただそれはまあ人の立場ですよね
僕から見て
日本の人口が世界中の銀行の1.5%かすぎないから
まあ
英語を話しているその何ですか人間の数でも全体の世界の麻婆パーセンチですぎない
から
醤油他の人間
我々住んでる時と同じ時期にこの地球に住んでる人間ともう何か話しできる
彼らの考え方彼らの豪華について知りたいならば
他の言葉も勉強しないといけない眉をが非常に便利なんですよね色んな人が英語を使え
ますから
しかしそれだけじゃないんですよねグライダー
例えば僕な南米のテロいきましたね
マイ中で中あそこはスペイン語を用いるスペイン語で次ましたけれども
あそこはですねインカ帝国なんですよね第インカの言葉はいけ超でこの特にくす加え
ピチュあそこに住んでいる皆さんが血中はで話し言ってるわけですよ
もちろんは第二が今すぐペチワ勉強するつもりはないけれどもそういう言葉も存在し
ます
まあ中国亡国中国もできますから
もう何ですか縦横形状の人間と話していくんもんですね
今アラブ語の勉強してるからアラブの方たちと彼らの考え方も
ある程度分理解できるようにまあ何ずつあるわけですよね
なぜおけばそのなぜ所業非常に大きなポイントなんですよ
なぜかというと
そういう動機がないと勉強したい
動議がないとながらがー
続きに封印ですよ
言葉勉強すると非常にゆっくりですからゆっくりですか何か勉強してもですねええ
その
記憶したい
その非常に努力してもですねなかなか記憶できない
それは言葉の免許技術ね
だから他3社が起こりやすいだからいいのに同型が強ければ
のはないうそなんですかアラブの文化に異常に興味あります
あるいはこれからその国町と影
こういう動議がいいやに前第一なんだけれども
まあそれがあっても時々まあ弱くなるわけでしょ
だからもっと機械的に機械的に電球をするその目標
この線日も[ __ ]について少し降りましたけれども非常に助かるん
でしょ今毎日
3つの言葉を勉強する舞一応目標はあるけれども
井戸キーちょっとにやりたくないとか何か他のことをやり
よりやりたいとないその時に少なくとも約100の単語を
氏のリンクのシステムで保存して新しい単語
知らない単語
あの
オンラインの技術調べて北条数必ずやらないといけません
それは前に仕上げますだから今
鈴木の根れっしょん米を見せしますけれどもそれあなぶぶですけれども
食に青いの単語が私も知らない看護
なんですよ
でいちいち調べて保存しておきます
黄色になってしまいます
でそれと同じプロセスが3つの単語で毎日
今やってますだからのリングを透明であの
みると
毎日約以上
鈴を作りましたリンクは8 y 返事9
だから言葉を保存すると即やリンクを
作るというわけなんですよで僕は必ず毎日自分に対して約束した
逆単語毎日かっ言葉ごとに保存しますという約束を守ってますだから
皆さんに対してはまず1つはですねあのー
それほどたくそいほどべその英語でも何でもそれほど勉強したくないけれどもあるが+
石が多いから道着があってもその動議がによう待って弱くなってですねやめましたとか
だからその文法とかそういうもん
どうしても勉強しにくいものどうしても覚えてもボイス0
覚えても使えないそういうようなものじゃなくて
広い
内容を聞いたり読んだりでその中で毎日
や負担になる103後からず新しい単語
訪れる
そういうようなまあいえば気配的
あの
まあそのバカじゃないけどいつも無駄まあバーガーなので
行動やろう
自分に対して約束よれば自ずから
3カ月間たったら6カ月間たったらかなりの進歩に何
約束しますから
一つお願いしますやってみてください
そして
北
[ __ ]の d さーん
きゅっきゅちゃん元号4プロ佐藤
あーならん
ん